туга математика виленкін я встигав
турчин її програми заспівала другі чорні
програми були активними учасниками
обороні ми перебувала напастей на музику
з нашими модераторами і
нашу та миту було показати та резерву для
розван теж немає дружини та програми а б не
порушить йти засідка на півдні хуана
подумалось а засіки принцип системності
там
раз монтажу не програми пак помираючих
було зазору honda в суді на іспит
ударних ви багато хто ременях зональної
світло не підготовки учень програмі
таким чином і реалізував і принцип
жити cool і зірка йєті я більше ви мої
даються ваще і таким чином ми
засмічення далася вона обидва воскові такі ви
багато книг і віддаються травертин і он і
пов'язання з великим і середнім
застосування
знати про практичні ситуації хоча
вчення програмі
дуже азмі що вимили ним і в усіх
класах значно проводжаючи діяльність
результати над знанням та й усьому можна
перука анотація наших матеріалах і ким і
подавала увібрати цій потворності до 1-го
аналітичну групу у вигляді суміші курс
рубля лапід корінних сума соляри
харвича крем не
ти мені менше ми ще більше і вийняла її
програмі змістило акценти на вид знанням
їх результатів на діалізі другий спосіб
ми змогли також грахово ти про зайти
в 4 столітті і брав і у вартових умовляння не
рахунок необхідності реалізації
диференційований підхід у я не буду за
1 concord з уват ці зради ванни
опис у матеріалах
фокси ключових в мох ключових змін на
цієї ре
вище хочеш за значить і там шукаємо
автори змін модератори bull і відлили
григорівна я михаль на парі прошу
був відвіс знайти вже багато всередині манія
державного стандарту і служать і
нато і суміш підручнику столітті був і видай
не зате іржавий кішки там і про позиції в
4 ви чим цей істив рахунку перенесений на
вас місцю з класу до класу
заради жувальної буду не смагляві рахова
ти був і хочу розгорнути біля вагона т.ч.
не менше 89 доби умовляння не було
тусувалася з міс тупить ручних івкіна я
її реалізованих у них методи відвикла
це і прокладок і наводила лілія
Михайлівна
через самі придатки спить ручка вчення
програмі на моя дружина' його завучу ось і
провалу на згадку жодних прав щодо чехів
школі не вчиться особі важливі кричить крісло
я хочу сказати ще про те ще будемо
такі справи не знайдеш дискусії
харчування та cessna сувалася і тут уже я
конкретно скажу радість мабуть не
чисел у наших 20
пищить записую про подавала їх
повернути цю 1 класу
ми напали на майно та матеріал на
відповідай на склади для мишки у великого
класу і крем то ваще в на явних
петроченко queen скрупульозні реалізований
там ці зради на євро хова не саме
рятується проблеми
це пов'язано з темою у нумерації чисел
вмаєш від стада давай не увагу можна
до речі, вручається за нашу лікувальну
програму про перший клас дописуючи
пропонують хлопець з ти до іншого але тут
був і вагоні і такі аргументи вони
контр-аргумент і то муцій матеріал
заклавши замість вууу великому класі хоча
значить вона спорядження ви можете ременя
його за свій не на випадково ти врятований про
ітані ще на один щабель осені таблиць
множе не v4 pro понурив чат і часто
таблиці множення fps в іншому класі
прошу часті ну в третьому при владі
не хочу жодного образу про обличчя я
аргументу x a move 4 як було тусується
784 задають дітям чити на канікулах
таблиці чоловікові, що бив нічим, ну, ми не
покладемо і системі протези все ще треба
таблицю розриву ти у чині
наша позиція така ще в іншому ucla
сидить і мати пізнаємо це з принципів
володіння таблиць він і з вини
виконного суспільстві непросту через
таблиці ми можемо, а вже ви можуть з над і
всі таблиці та дробовик місце до 3
класів тут у нас по разу мене і
записуй
можна ще одну його фразу знайшли ту ж
було капора суворо ніж елінор була skoda
дітям теж вихолощена хам
готова і алгебра і що й таким чином ми
розриваємо ними стоп лише початківцю
школою та основну ми сперечаємося проблема для
діток
п'ятому класі я хочу сказати навіть астані
моя фраза душа горить залишити їжу розван
також не
хорошої програми з математики ми
читала ваше інтерв'ю лілія михайлівна
ще у нас на явні вигадай станція немає
влади математичні природні че
науки в нашій Україні та
там ще сам ці предмети спадають усного
пихал узи шукай творять міц нашої держави